john easton says he got three questions
so we'll go with the first one
do you guys think that anime and eastern
cartoons have become popular due to the
decline in quality in western shows yes
well i'll answer this first i i grew up
watching anime because
american shows are like episodic
and anime is like you know what's it
called like a serial like yes continuous
and so watching like dragon ball z
growing up
what happens next and they always live
in the cliffhanger you know like goku's
about to go super saiyan you're like i
gotta see the next episode oh man
and you have this really long story
where someone asks you like what's
happening in this episode oh dude you
gotta watch a hundred episodes to figure
out what's happening here
and then american shows it was like at
the end of every every show it just
restarts
yes it's just like nothing changes and
it was just gag humor
and i wasn't a big end of it i don't
know what do you guys think
do you want to go first no no you go
ahead well there's a lot of history i've
been studying the history of comics for
a long time because i
uh before i did silly political strips i
was trying to get into indie comics
again
and um if you study sort of what
happened to american comics in the past
few decades
there was a massive bubble in 92-93 so
image comics around 92
when spawn was coming out and it was
getting formed was like the peak of
american comics
since i want to say the 50s 40s
something like that
the golden age in the silver age was
happening so then the bubble burst for
various reasons and then there was a lot
of
stores closing in the mid to late 90s
because of the speculator market so long
story short is a lot of creators
ended up scattering and doing what
they're doing now which is um
crowdfunding a lot of their comic strips
so you get a lot of the
creators who want to i don't know
i create an indiegogo or something like
that and i say hey everyone who follows
me if you want to buy this book you can
back the book
but what happens in japan there's there
was a famous story a couple of weeks ago
or a couple of days ago
where one manga series called demon
slayer i think is outselling the entire
american comics industry wow just one
well hold on hold on
mango that was the second question as
animators what do you think of the demon
slayer movie
okay i never saw it yeah but the the
story is interesting because
all right real real quick demon slayer
in america is outselling entire american
comics
i'm not sure in america but maybe
worldwide like if you go to barnes noble
right now right
if you look at the comics section the
graphic novel section the western comics
versus the manga section
the manga section is almost always three
times the size
for various reasons but people here even
want to read more manga like young
people want to read manga more than
american comics they're more into it for
numerous reasons i've always said like
manga is like the mma versus
if you've ever seen those uh videos of
the mma fighter versus like the
tai chi fighter and it's just like a
brutal beatdown of like
american comics look really great but if
you pit american comics versus manga
manga is going to win
every time why is it there's i could do
a whole
feast i'll tell you this when i see
these like ultra woke trash comics
yeah no one wants anywhere near that
nobody wants why did that happen
it seems like that happened to comics in
a way that it just hasn't happened to
other
so most people industries lean to the
left but it just seems like
comics are really far to the left
compared to the other ones and in a much
more overt way
movies and television shows will have a
left wing message
but they're not like making a big deal
of the fact that they are having a
left-wing message not as often
yeah but but that's but why comics
why don't the same rules apply to these
other probably because there's about
disney bought there
no hold on my my assumption is that
comic sales were slumping
and these companies thought we're only
getting white men
we have this whole untapped audience of
diversity of like you know non-white
female et cetera so how could yes that's
what a lot of them do they think
their core audience is this one group
and how do we expand into all these
other areas
so what they start doing is making
diverse
messages because they think that's what
people want instead of realizing
nobody wants that and maybe you should
just make
so so i'll put it this way it used to be
that if you were a
tv host you were you are super rich now
there's
millions of hosts who do youtube shows
who are all doing well
who are well off but not like 50 million
dollars like you know hannity is
it's changing so these comics start
seeing their sales decline and instead
of saying
let's make another brand new comic for
this market they say
let's make iron man a young black woman
because then
the iron man fans will watch and read
and the
other communities who don't now will and
it's like no no now you've just made a
a weird character that nobody cares
about yeah it doesn't work that way
i look at i look at manga it's not in
there
like i got i got crunchyroll man and i'm
like each and every one of these action
shows i just watch them like wow it's
actually pretty good well
i've never watched any anime um but
i'm curious i mean it could also just be
that the stories are more interesting to
people yeah what's your thesis george at
least
man all right so i i don't know if you
guys know but like there was a company
called tokyo pop back in the
mid 2000s that was translating a lot of
manga
back before the uh recession of 2007-8
there was
a long story short they were trying to
do original english manga and i was
involved with that stuff i had my first
book was published through them
um but what was happening with manga in
those years and even in the late 90s was
a lot of manga was getting published
in english that's why they started doing
the whole um
if you the formats going from right to
left because in the original
japanese they read from right to left so
a lot of
it seemed foreign and weird at first but
they weren't flipping
the books anymore you had companies like
viz
uh tokyo pop uh
anyway there were a lot of companies
doing this but you want to talk about
diversity for example like there were so
many
female creators in japan creating uh
let's say
shoujo series that's a girl series you
know
i've got a couple of uh rumiko takahashi
uh masami suda for me rumiko didn't
yasha and
dude she did so many and if you want to
talk about like female creators and
those are power range
massive she's one of the richest uh
manga creators in history
woman and there was no i there was no
inkling of like oh she was oppressed or
she wasn't she just made good books and
she found an
audience that wanted to buy and read her
stuff they were
crazy about it even here in the states
that's why if i go to barnes noble
i try to like talk to some people like
hey why do you read this series
and they just tell me oh i just like the
story i want to find out what's
happening
next even though it's not in color
americans love books and color but
if you give them like berserk the
creator of berserk kentaro miura
recently died
everybody now was talking about all of
last week we're talking about how much
they love berserk
it's a black and white series one of the
coolest darkest fantasy series you've
ever heard of
they love that series is it by romiko uh
berserk yeah no that's kantara majora uh
yeah he
i was going to say though uh uh for in
in yasha what year was that 90s
uh 80s i want to say that the manga at
least the
anime would have been 90s so so inuyasha
is about a furry
and ranma is about a transgender martial
artist really
but there's a reason i don't watch anime
but people were reading those i'm
just like i'm grossly mischaracterizing
the enemies i was awesome no but in a
way i mean
really that gives you an idea of the
people just wanted to read a story that
they wanted to enjoy there was no
uh pushing of an ideology for them
especially manga story is the king
you've got uh
the writer all right so you've got the
mangaka
who is the writer artist who has
assistants working with them and then
you've got the editor who helps them
write the stories
but they're really focused on what's how
how do i get the readers to read the
next chapter always
they're planning the story in such a way
like i just started getting onto one
piece and i can't get enough of it
it's so fun and i want to find out
what's happening next and i just like
the characters i like the world it's fun
to read
an american comic nowadays like i open
it and i have to push myself i have to
force myself
to turn the page it's so boring and i
can't explain why but when i read a
manga
i can't put them down yeah it's it's
crazy but it's a martial arts thing to
me like i
just i grew up reading manga my whole
life
i i i grew up hanging out at comic shops
and they've just always been born to me
have you but if you saw a manga on the
shelf like did you
feel yeah dude full metal alchemist
you've got to know what happens next the
politics of it was brilliant
yeah i loved the 92 91 is when i got
into comics i was reading like the
infinity gauntlet
x-force was all right x-men they were
good stories i mean the relationship
between gene gray and like
jubilee for like cyclops and like you
know colossus or whatever
and then and spawn came out and it was
like oh this is amazing this is jim
lee's
started a new company with image and
then maybe they just fell into the
spectacle i mean mar
marvel got bought that industry got
torched by disney basically it looks
like
marvel was struggling for a long time if
you look at the history of what happened
with image those
all right tom mcfarlane uh rob liefeld
and all those guys they were originally
they were the top guys at marvel and
they all decided to quit at the same
time
and form image comics there was this
whole flip of like the whole industry
turned upside down
and everyone was like oh all right so a
few years later there was something
called the speculator market which
a lot of comic books were selling uh
like a superman number one sold for a
ton of money and everyone's like oh i
gotta buy
issue one of this book and there's all
these variant covers
it's super rare so i have to invest in
this comic so what ended up happening
unfortunately was
image comics was so successful that they
were selling millions and millions of
copies of their first issues
everyone was buying them and it created
a bubble by accident and then the bubble
popped
so all these comic shops like novelty
comic shops that used to be card shops
opened and then closed and everyone saw
the recessions like oh comics are over
but it was just a bubble so image comics
is an interesting anomaly
and then all right so they were
struggling for a while and then uh image
comics did
all right they had walking dead which
was really really successful
robert kirkman ended up becoming a
partner at image after
uh walking dead was doing really good um
which is another black and white book
incidentally and everybody wanted to
it was one of those page turner books
that everyone wants to find out what
happens next
just go back to the 80s man and it was
just
a lot of really great stuff yeah and
then i don't know what happened like 90s
2000s
ebay destroyed the market what i mean is
the writing
so we're talking about like manga and
anime versus comics right
so i'm i'm growing up and i'm reading
comics
in like 2000 and they're getting dry and
boring and i'm reading and i'm just like
you know what it might be i can only
read about cyclops so many times yeah
sure
but you know with i started watching
dragon ball z
i watched that in the 90s i was a little
kid it was on it was it was
i turned on channel 50 at 8 in the
morning it was like or i think the only
way to watch it was in spanish
and so there was like that scene where
vegeta that's why you said vegeta is
about to kill napa
and napa goes poor and then vegeta
and i'm like vodka and then uh but then
you know i'm a little kid and i started
watching and i'm like whoa and like the
lore was really cool because i'd watch
an episode
and then someone would start telling me
like here's this character here's what
here's
here's what happened 10 years ago i'm
like whoa and i'm getting really really
into it i opened a comic
yeah like a lot of the x-men lore and
like the dc lore stuff was interesting
but it started to get boring and then
the difference is
there's so much different manga that are
that are long that are in depth that
have different characters
that i could just find the one that i
thought was really good and stick to it
and watch it or read it and get to the
whole thing
i don't know man you you compare like
the full metal alchemist the politics of
that manga
brilliant like government corruption and
just the general
aspect of how they have the powers they
have alchemy they can just make things
with code like they write on the tables
or whatever
and then you have death note which is
probably one of the greatest fantastic
yeah just brilliant yeah and that's like
what can we say
right now mcu cool i like the mcu movies
but it's regurgitated
they're not hiring or searching for new
talent like the way that manga
they alright shonen jump and all those
companies over there they have talent
searches all the time
submit your stuff submit a chapter the
editors will pick the best
you get to talk to an editor maybe you
get to develop a series over here in the
states
all right so you got even veteran
creators i was talking to a veteran
creator who
has multiple eisner awards super amazing
he used to almost say his name out of
respect i guess
but like he can't find work anymore
because the editors running
marvel dc they won't even talk to him
because they're woke
they're woke and he let's say is
conservative let's say there's a whole
bunch of
i won't name names but there's a whole
bunch of conservative creators who can't
find
work in the industry but they're able to
get crowdfunding there are some of them
who
have hundreds of thousands of dollars a
couple of them broke even millions on
their books
what should is there like an american
shonen jump no should there i mean there
is a translated version
of shonen jump right i mean like our
version of
there needs to be an anthology yes the
problem is with printing
i don't know if i mentioned last time i
print my own books at home let's say
i can't do a lot like i'm not like i'm
doing all this stuff by myself but like
to print and color is so expensive you
would have to print tens of thousands of
books just to break even let's say yeah
but you ship but it doesn't
doesn't show them do the manga chapters
and they do it in black and white but
they can yeah
they have it's called an anthology if
you've ever seen heavy metal
in america um but yeah if you look at
sean and jump
uh pulp used to do it back in the 90s
too there needs to be
things like talent searches anthologies
creators
creators nowadays like we're trying to
do
indie comics it's just that to get
funded to do them
is so hard and those of us who get
funded we're working super slow because
like i have a book called mary sue for
instance that just got it got funded
like
months ago and i'm trying to find time
to work on it
it just barely got funding thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you